the Joe Rogan experience what is
happening right now with this virus
where everybody's being forced indoors
and forced us to stop work it's a it's a
terrible thing for people financially
but it is in a sense a reset button it's
a real reset button to know that this
shitty job that you hate going to could
go away at any moment because all jobs
could go away in any moment it's a real
wake-up call because even the good jobs
are going away right if you're in San
Francisco you have the best job in the
world guess what you can't even go there
right you might have the best job you're
so [ __ ] pumped to go to work every
day you can't go you can't go so that
can be taken away from you too so if
you're living a [ __ ] life like
recognize that all of this for everybody
could go away right if Yellowstone blows
half the people die right easily easily
maybe more maybe more
that [ __ ] could easily go sure
we we need these little catastrophes
sometimes just to let us understand that
the window of time that we've been
existing in that's been relatively free
of disaster is unique and that's not
normal normal is madness
normal is we're in the middle of a
[ __ ] shooting gallery spending a
thousand miles an hour around fireball
that's normal and every now and then
[ __ ] flies into our atmosphere and
wrecks havoc this is why I love Hollow
Earth theory man you ever get into that
[ __ ] is that for people to get kicked
out of the Flat Earth Society yeah how
flattered is people look down hollow but
hollow hollow Hollow Earth is like to me
my favorite of them all because - like
it's ideas like yeah humans have been on
the planet for a long time and if we
want to go into like the cool idea of
the Atlanteans and advanced
civilizations at some point if you can't
create a way to protect from the meteor
impacts and you're looking to create a
sustaining civilization you're gonna
want to go in there man and so to me
it's such a [ __ ] cool idea that in
the core of the earth is another Sun
that has an advanced civilization that
hasn't been disrupted by the [ __ ] that
happens on the surface of the planet
it turns the earth into a spaceship
inside the spaceship for these advanced
beings and outside the spaceship it's
like a celestial fungus it's like
growing out the cyst or it's like
another way to put it would be outside
the spaceship is Mad Max like covering
outside the spaceship is just a bunch of
like you know us that are inside the
thing who have basically been completely
disrupted over and over and over again
so they're they have no idea what
history is they have no idea where the
planet came from they don't know
anything and now we've sort of grown out
of control all around the ship and so
this kind of [ __ ] that's happening is
like turning on the windshield wipers
it's like hey man you got humans on you
you know that right man you're like
crawling with them oh [ __ ]
wipe them out get rid of them let's just
scrub the [ __ ] surface do with some
earthquakes Yellowstone is just a
windshield wiper for the people who live
inside the planet well you know what
humans are man really a vector for ideas
yeah it's ideas that change everything
the humans just do the work of the ideas
but what we are we're the first thing
that can manipulate our environment that
has ideas we're the first thing with
ideas all these other animals they had
instincts they had ideas in terms of
like trying to figure out the best
patterns to acquire food how to sneak up
on birds yeah but if you think cats have
ideas well guess what they all have the
same [ __ ] idea cats aren't inventing
[ __ ] you know they're not inventing
things there's a specific kind of idea
that's unique to a human being
regardless of the scent chance of other
animals ours is unique in that it allows
us to make stuff not just little things
we can make gigantic machines that
travel in a space and all the the wild
creations of human beings all came out
of ideas we think it's all humans but
true we we're the ones that put four but
if you're a thing that wants to get born
you need a host you get that curious ape
to just been trying to figure out better
ways to stab its neighbor with a spear
get that thing and slowly infect it with
ideas ideas of new stuff to me
and then it goes out and does the work
for you and then you take over the earth
the ideas have taken over the earth the
people are just the toys the ideas now
if instead of ideas you said demons I
mean that's that's literally what people
used to think was happening to folks
when they did terrible things they had
bad ideas they acted on those bad ideas
and ancient religions thought of those
ideas like there were demons like these
people were possessed that was a common
thought that someone's possessed by a
demon
they we are all possessed by ideas and
some possessed by them more than others
like Elon Musk is particularly haunted
he's possessed by ideas and what does he
do well you look at what he's done he's
one guy that's probably had more of an
impact on our perception of what the
future holds in terms of technology than
any other one individual human being
that is widely known of like he is a
famous human like he is I mean he's
doing Tesla which is the most advanced
electric cars in the world they're
insane yeah then he's doing this [ __ ]
loop thing right the hyper or the the
boring project where he's boring
who's doing the Hyperloop he's doing the
boring project is making tunnels under
LA and Vegas and you gonna be able to
shoot through those tunnels going 120
miles an hour then he's making Rockets
that shoot up into space
oh and solar power - yeah like what how
was one guys doing all this what's going
on there well that guy's infected by
ideas that guy probably has a huge
receptor and ideas have clung on to him
just like some girls have big tits
some people have crazy parts of their
brain that soaks in ideas there's no
rhyme or reason to why but what what
they are is an antenna for ideas those
ideas come up you're like wow I'm glad I
thought of that and then you go to work
on fracking you gotta work on all kinds
of different crazy things they change
the world forever whoever invented
Fukushima right he's like I'm figuring
out how to shut it off when that time
comes we'll figure it out no one ever
does but that person talked people or
that group of people whose ideas all
coincided talked people into building a
gigantic nuclear furnace that you can
never shut off yeah
how crazy is that oh that's crazy that's
crazy we scan the skies for meteor
impacts but we have no way to scan human
consciousness for some incoming yes yeah
because some ideas coming in are gonna
be great but there's gonna be a few
there are really bad ideas like you know
Hitler he had an idea yeah it was a bad
[ __ ] idea and the implement that idea
was just floating an astral plane
gradually just shooting towards Hitler's
but I did that ideas fueled by an
ecosystem and let just like you're
fueled by nutrients right human beings
are fueled by plants and fish and
animals and vitamins and all these
different things well you're these ideas
are fueled they're fueled by insecurity
and ego and lust and greed and jealousy
and anger and virtue and love and
prosperity and comfort and and community
and all those different components of
human consciousness all interact with
this idea so the idea becomes like it
just hitches a ride and hitches a ride
with all these ideas that that already
exists in your brain and then with these
pre-existing structures like businesses
and warehouses and all these different
things that we use to make stuff and
then ship it out then the idea becomes a
thing and then the idea winds up in the
belly of a seagull because it looks like
a fish whoops sorry you're dead you're
dead seagull you couldn't figure out
that that's a bottle cap not a fish and
that this is this is how things change
they don't just change because of people
we're blaming ourselves and it is
definitely us that's doing the work but
it's all coming out of ideas if we
thought of ideas as a life force instead
of thinking ideas is like something you
own yeah something you hold but even
though you do deserve credit for your
ideas because your discipline to sit
down and try to cultivate these ideas
accelerates the production of those
ideas and exercises the muscle through
which those ideas come through focus and
energy so you deserve credit for it I'm
not is not socialist way of looking at
it but everybody that has an idea that's
really good will tell you it's like it
came out of no
like every great bit that you've ever
had it's like pop a light bulb goes off
and you have this thought and it comes
out of nowhere right that's like most
things did you write that are really
cool they kind of come out of nowhere
yeah you just sit there and then also do
you think of things and you write them
out they're like they're an idea that
you're wrestling you just catch them and
just catch them
[Applause]